[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host he is also the host of the fine
print our newest and most popular
podcast right now people are zooming in
wanting to know what is in
the fine print uh this week's episode
all about christmas
getting ready and uh making sure these
things happen
so we have a new book coming out today
uh the pre-sale on it starts today i um
i've not written a major trade book in
eight years
uh ramsey personalities have done them
all and the last one i wrote a co-wrote
with rachel which was smart money smart
kids and that was the number one best
seller uh so we've been putting uh all
of you guys you ramsey personalities
forward including king coleman's book
was actually hit the street last week
and will be a new york times bestseller
i'm sure or a national bestseller i'm
sure as will uh as was christie's uh
take back your time christy wright's
book a few a few weeks back a few months
back and so um this book will actually
be on the street on january the 11th
it's called baby steps millionaires how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can too
and uh
ramsey personality at the time chris
hogan did a book called everyday
millionaires here that was a bestseller
and a big seller did very very well and
it was all about the study that we had
done uh and all about the research that
was done on millionaires and uh everyday
millionaires was about everyday people
who had become millionaires while we
were doing that i started seeing
that uh the baby steps
us teaching the baby steps was often
resulting in people becoming
millionaires if they followed the baby
steps and so a subset of millionaires uh
out there is the ones that have actually
followed our baby steps and have done it
and there's tens of thousands of them
that are millionaires uh but uh we see
them on the debt free stage all the time
it's not unusual for someone to do a
debt-free scream with their house being
paid off and with their paid for home in
conjunction with the current balance on
their
uh uh retirement plan that they have a
million dollar net worth it's not that
unusual at all and so we're seeing baby
steps millionaires in our lobby all the
time we're seeing them at our events
they're everywhere yeah i've loved
having a front row seat meeting these
people and there really are people you'd
never even realize are millionaires
because they're not lavish people
they're the everyday hard-working people
who follow these steps and over the
course of five seven 10 15 years of
following the steps and paying off their
home early go figure they become
millionaires yeah
absolutely it's a slow and steady way
and so if you are uh deeply
immersed in the ramsey stuff and you're
following the baby steps to a t and
you've read the total money makeover and
you're doing it exactly like we teach
there uh you may not need to read this
book
other than for the inspiration of all
the people who have actually become
millionaires before you uh that are
encouraging you that you can do it so
it's all about stories of people that
have really done it
uh from any possible background and they
followed the baby steps and it's about
the detail inside the investing side
of the baby steps baby step four five
six the things that lead you into
becoming a millionaire uh it's not about
getting out of debt it's not about um
budgeting
uh uh um you know it's about the baby
steps here's what they are and the
important ones for the millionaire part
is you get out of debt so that
you can invest so that you can invest in
your retirement so that you can invest
in your kids college so that you can get
your home paid off so that you can
increase your generosity and the stories
of these individuals that have done this
um
and uh mixed with just hour 30 years of
me sitting in this seat uh is what
birthed this book and so it is different
than everyday millionaires chris hogan's
book that we published
everyday millionaires was all about the
study
and this book is all about the exact
baby steps exactly how they lead you to
millionaires it's also about the things
that the myths that people believe
that they say well i can't get there
people like me
can't get there
and we break a whole bunch of that down
or the myth that i can't get there
because i really wouldn't want to get
there because wealthy is evil you're
evil if you're wealthy and so we
addressed some of those things as well
dressed a little bit of that legacy
journey as well
and so
i don't have a whole lot of new ideas so
if you've read everything i've written
and you listen to this podcast every
single day this book is not going to be
like well that's a whole new thing it's
not i thought you were going to unleash
baby step 8. no it's more of the same i
mean it is more the same but but if you
really want to see and you've got this
friend who says well it's not possible
today
this is the proof text
i can show you that
not only is it possible it's probable
that you would become a millionaire if
you do exactly what we show you to do
because it's been done tens of thousands
of times
this is not a theory yes and a lot of
people have theories they go well dave i
disagree and here's my theory if you do
this and you do this and you get fancy
over here that's going to be a faster
way to become a millionaire what i love
about this book is it's you saying hey
we've created thousands upon thousands
of millionaires and here's what they did
yeah and you can too so i'll go ahead
and and tell you you know like it was
already uh you know went on sale
pre-sale this morning and somebody i was
just reading some of the comments on
instagram there's always some butthole
on instagram and um he's like oh just
another ramsey book saying the same
thing yeah you're right dude actually
you're fairly you're fairly right we are
saying the same thing that we've always
said uh because it continues to work
and yet this is a different way looking
at it and then we did publish the entire
study
for the millionaires that was done for
the chris hogan book the night ramsey
it's my study i mean ramsey research did
it i own the company and so ramsay
researched a study on the largest study
on millionaires ever done is in the
appendix
as backup material and um so
uh you can you know you'll get the you
can read the study and you can see
here's how the baby steps work and
here's how
mathematically with like stuff like
arithmetic
you know that will cause you to be a
millionaire is the proof is there and so
it it if you've got a friend who doesn't
think they can do it this is your book
to tell them they can do it if you're
wondering if you can do it this is the
book that'll tell you you can do it
if you're halfway through and you're
getting a little tired this is the book
that'll remind you if you stick with it
you're going to be able to do it um and
i also wrote a chapter in this that i
thought was interesting um
my editor honestly didn't agree with me
but uh i think that people don't go for
millionaire
because they confuse millionaire and
billionaire
millionaires don't have private jets
millionaires don't have six homes and
seven cars millionaires don't drive 250
000 400 000 lamborghinis that's what
billionaires do and a billionaire is a
thousand million huge gap if you have
ten thousand dollars you are much closer
to being a millionaire
than a millionaire is to being a
billionaire
wow and so if you see like jeff bezos
flying into space and that's what you
think of when you think a millionaire
you've got it wrong
and if that keeps you then from becoming
wealthy
as a millionaire because you thought it
was something it wasn't
i thought that was something that needed
to be addressed yeah that's interesting
i did address it so it's very very
math on it's very interesting i love
ratios and that kind of stuff that
sounds nerdy i like it yeah it's very in
there so baby steps millionaires at
ramseysolutions.com
it's all in there and of course if you
order there's a hundred dollars worth of
bonus items including the audiobook the
e-book the legacy journey audio book and
e-book the baby steps millionaires live
stream ramsey smart tax and a 30-day
free trial to ramsey plus all included
if you pre-purchase baby
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
george camel ramsey personality is my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey your host
this is the ramsay show common sense for
your dollars and cents open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five robert is in indianapolis hi robert
how are you
good how are you today better than i
deserve what's up
great so i had a question for you um my
wife and i have for several years been
thinking about buying a vacation
property overseas specifically in paris
um it's been a long-term dream
cool and uh with the pandemic and
whatnot we found that you know this
might actually be more workable
than we thought before and we might be
in a financial position to do so um
we've got full-time jobs and kids so it
wouldn't be something that we'd use more
than initially about eight weeks a year
but um
we've had a hard time transitioning from
earning to enjoying and we just aren't
really sure that this makes financial
sense for us at this point in time so i
want to get your opinion on that okay
what's the apartment cost
about 1.1 million and what's your net
worth
uh just short of 10 million okay all
right well that's a very reasonable
ratio and you'd be paying cash for it i
assume
good okay all right
so you're going to spend 10 of your net
worth on a toy
yep
i think that's reasonable
i don't have a problem with like a very
big jump it it is a big toy
so i have a couple of properties that
are not my main residence
the very first time i did this i bought
a 103 000 lake house
and when i pulled that 103 000 out and
it wasn't much of a house as you might
imagine but it was on the lake shut up
and there was a dock so be quiet and so
which is all i wanted i just wanted a
place to camp near the boat right but uh
it was a little bitty brick house and a
cute little house
and i pulled that money out of my mutual
funds and i broke out into a cold sweat
it was really hard for me to do
that's what you're experiencing except
you got another zero on it right
that that's that's pretty much exactly
it we've just found it like i said very
hard to think that psychological change
from from earning to enjoying and
inoculating things get out of control
which is probably where we're a little
uncomfortable with the idea the thing
that sharon and i do and that we teach
to high net worth individuals all the
time
two things will help you with that
one is uh ratios
and the ratio is that you're spending 10
percent of your net worth on this so the
way we look at ratios is this for a toy
a luxury item
if we put that much money in the middle
of the kitchen table and set it on fire
would our life change
answer in your case no it would not
change not much you know other than
you'd have a severe depression over
having burned a million dollars in the
middle ear table but
but i'm saying mathematically
mathematically you didn't ruin your life
now let's say you put five million
dollars in there now i'm starting to
worry about this is not a good idea you
follow me on the ratios
sure exactly now if you put five million
dollars in there and your net worth is
500 million
once again
we're not really worried about it
okay so you see what ratios do right and
so when they say that you know so and so
builds a a a billion dollar house but
they have a net worth of 200 billion
dollars the ratio is that's not spit
even though that's a lot of freaking
money for a house right so
ratios are one thing and in your case
that's why i was real comfortable that
the second thing that we do is
also on ratios we always watch our
generosity
and we want to make sure that we are
giving
and that we're filling up the ramsey
family foundation and we're doing other
stuff to help other people
uh that is equal to our luxury
spending or greater
and that also tells me that i'm
spiritually balanced and in check this
is not all about me i'm not in hedonism
mode where if i just get more stuff i'll
be happy and you're not that guy either
i can hear it in his voice can't you
george yeah he's not he's not a lavish
guy this is something they've worked
really hard for and you said it's been a
lifelong dream robert and so and it's
not a car i mean this is a house so this
is going to hopefully hold its value
over time i would think it's not a
depreciating lamborghini uh yeah and so
i feel good about this this purchase
it's just the emotions that you're
dealing with that's really the the
hindrance here then i guess the third
thing that kind of mixes in there for a
guy like you and a guy like me that
knows numbers is uh
a second home
a luxury item never makes mathematical
sense
never
you can never buy a yacht
and figure out what it costs you per
hour to use it it'll make you throw up
you can never buy a lake house and
figure out this cost me so much a night
to stay here when i stay at the lake
house which i've got a lake house if i
ever add that up it just will make my
head hurt make my head explode right but
it's not about that it doesn't make
sense you'd be better off to rent a bnb
airbnb you'd be better off to rent
something a thousand times before you
bought
you can you could you could rent an
apartment eight weeks a year in paris
for the rest of your life and still not
spend a million dollars
exactly and you'd probably laugh at the
car i drive because that's the
juxtaposition there is what what gets uh
gets me yeah and getting there so it
doesn't it doesn't make sense
financially a fifty thousand dollar car
doesn't make sense financially because
like you said both of the five hundred
dollar car the five thousand dollar car
will still get me to the exact same
location at pretty much the same time
with pretty much the same reliability
and so it doesn't
the point is is you've earned it
and you can enjoy it
while you balance it with ratios and
generosity and if you do all those
things it'll help you walk through this
spiritually and emotionally because
that's really all you're struggling with
and i agree are you agreed
absolutely no
is it a good time to buy real estate in
paris is it is it sucking over there i
don't know
well it
it's not as strong as it has been in the
past it hasn't run up like it has here
in the united states lately so you can
get i mean what we would consider
something decent and a good section of
paris for yeah
i know it's not measured in square
footage it's probably measured in
hectares or something but what's the
square footage you get for a thousand
bucks and are for a million bucks in
paris
well it depends what part of the city
you're in i know but what are you
looking at about
about 800 square feet yeah okay so it's
it's like uh comparative to manhattan
yeah roughly speaking new york san
francisco yeah okay robert i'm just
curious how did you get to a 10 million
net worth what was the key
well you know i
when i was young my father worked in the
aviation industry in the 80s and the 90s
where it was up and down just like crazy
and i remember growing up when i was in
middle school where
i you know things were not good i could
tell that my parents were concerned even
if they didn't really communicate that
there might be a job loss in the future
and
i i
learned very young that i was not going
to be in a position where someone else
or some other circumstance controlled
my life like that
um so you didn't you didn't inherit any
of this money
no what's your career field
uh engineering okay number one of uh
baby steps millionaires number one in
the millionaire study that we did
um so you just invested like crazy over
the course of your career
yeah when i graduated i realized that
you know if i was earning 30 and i saved
10 that was you know some time that i
could fight back for myself but if i was
saving 20 i could buy back more time so
i dialed down my spending when i was
young really low how old are you and
just packed it away and saving uh 45
wow you slammed it
well done good job man maybe a little
too much but no i i think well yeah you
might you you do need to loosen up now
because you've not practiced the
enjoyment muscle and you may not have
practiced the generosity muscle enough
both of those muscles may be
underdeveloped and so the enjoyment
muscle and the generosity muscle need to
come with the saving and investing
muscle all three muscles must be built
to have a good life with money
and it's actually what we talk about in
this new book a lot and baby steps
millionaires talk about this stuff a lot
a lot of the same things we just talked
about with him
and uh by the way went on pre-sale today
if you're joining us late in the hour
here
thanks robert that was a great
discussion awesome 10 million dollars 45
years old amazing by a million dollar
800 square foot flat
in paris
not a call i've ever gotten in 30 years
this is the ramsey shop
life is full of firsts
[Music]
the first and longest serving christian
health cost sharing ministry chm has
shared medical expenses for its members
since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage tim and michelle are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you great welcome good to have you
where do you guys live
omaha nebraska yes all the way to
nashville to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off we paid off a
hundred and eleven thousand and five
hundred dollars
way to go guys and how long did that
take you four years and eight months all
right i love it and your range of income
during that time we started off at a
little over eighty four thousand and we
finished off at a little over 95 000.
good for you guys what do y'all do for a
living i'm a radiology technologist
specializing in mri
i'm a welder very good cool so what kind
of debt was your hundred and twelve
thousand
a private student loan was the bulk of
it two car loans and two credit cards no
we're kind of normal yes
[Laughter]
how long have you been married
about 20 years now yeah all right well
congratulations thank you so four years
and eight months ago you started ramsey
journey tell me about that what happened
uh well it uh it started when we moved
from california to nebraska
i was pretty gung-ho about paying off
our credit card debt and my co-worker
noticed this and she gifted me your book
thank you jessica gill
and uh at the time though i was doing
such a good job that i didn't think i
needed to read it so i kind of tossed it
aside and we moved to nebraska things
were going well we bought a house and we
didn't have any furniture so i started
using the credit cards again of course
oh yeah
tim tim knew better than that yeah yeah
well he let me do what i wanted yes i
can tell
because i'm a really thrifty shopper so
yeah things were going fine
of course i maxed out the credit cards
filling up the house
but things were still under control i
had this all under control
uh and then of course life happens and
both the cars decided to crap out on us
at the same time no yes and they were
both saturns so
we were told that they were not worth
what it was going to cost to fix them
yeah so all of a sudden i looked up and
we had two car loans two maxed out
credit cards a mortgage and still the
student loan
and i thought you know maybe i should
read that book that jessica
gifted us
was it a paperweight up until that point
yeah pretty much yeah the coaster oh
yeah
and so i read it and i got through it in
a week and absolutely loved it and i
rushed at him and i said you have got to
read this we need to do this he rolled
his eyes at me and he said we do not
need a get rich quick scene and i said
no no that's not what this is yeah i
like him
and he is so to placate me to shut me up
he said fine fine give me the book he
read it in two days and he said we got
to do this yep that's exactly what he
said yes
and right after that and i said okay now
i heard of this thing called fpu and
he's like okay so we got through that we
didn't went to financial peace
university yeah we uh we bought it
online and we were so excited every
night to do that wow and we immediately
started and
four years later here we are five years
later yeah
just binge watch fpu like tiger king or
something we really really did we were
so excited every night to watch that yes
it was yeah that's incredible so at what
point did you go oh this isn't a get
rich quick scheme this is get rich slow
uh when i read the book i was like this
is not a good
scheme it's something we have to work
through and go through all the steps yes
process yeah so four years and eight
months what were those things that you
did tactically that actually made you
see the progress
you know the
when i started
the budget i got really scared
because in the beginning
the bills really didn't match
what we were making and i was scared
that we weren't going to be able to do
it
but
just starting the steps really just
starting out and
just making the small amount of progress
making the little
changes here and there not spending as
much on the grocery not not eating out
that that was a real big one for us
yeah making that changes to not eat out
so much say no to you know the kids
those start to add up you you think that
those are small changes that that's not
going to make that much of a difference
but you know the next month and the
month after that all of a sudden oh my
gosh it really is and i'm like and we
are making progress you know and
and then it's you you start to see the
dents you know becoming bigger and
bigger yeah that's incredible so did you
guys have cheerleaders along the way or
did people think you were crazy other
than your friend who gifted you the book
uh we had our kids our families
but there were some people that were
thinking we were nuts
and those motivate me more than the
children
i think our teenagers actually were our
biggest cheerleaders we shared
everything with them yeah um along the
way uh because we didn't want them to
fall into the same trap
and they they really motivated us did
they get involved in the process they
did they definitely what were they doing
they honestly um i i remember um our
kids the most uh well when i would um
make big um
uh progress and i would say we finished
off um a card um and i would take down
our charts that we would uh color in the
boys would come i want to finish it i
want to color it in i i want to do it i
was like yeah wow they're they're
teenagers and they actually want to do
this i'm like oh that's that's great
yeah
they saw it as an art project yeah
that's great i know
i love it very cool very cool well done
you guys all right when somebody asks
what do you tell them the key is
i want to get this right because this is
important to me okay um
to me the secret to this is creative
tenacity
good phrase haven't heard that one yes
thank you
i'm speaking to everyone who feels like
that their particular
life does not allow them to work the
problem
when we started this journey we both
were working jobs that did not allow us
to have second jobs we had crazy shifts
and we didn't have anything that we
could sell either so like i've heard you
say several times dave if that is off
the table
what do you do
you donate plasma and while you're lying
on that table you do as many online
surveys as you can
okay
then also you can download a lot of
cashback apps like ibotta or get upside
or rakuten
these are small things but they can add
up i got about two thousand dollars just
from those apps alone you can also wrap
your car
okay did you do that
no i i i tried we called yeah i i tried
but omaha nebraska apparently isn't a
big enough area yeah yeah
but i mean i i looked into it so fun
yeah exactly maybe you i would do that
yeah
but we also were able to rent out a room
in our house maybe these ideas don't
work for you but you can find something
that does work for you amen the point
and there's a lot of great ideas on
pinterest the dave ramsey website has
articles that list a lot of the apps
that i didn't list
and um facebook the ramsey um baby steps
community there's a lot of collaboration
going on there ideas being bounced
around the point is you can be creative
without being ish
just don't give up this is totally
possible don't quit bring her in my in
charge of the marketing yes this is
incredible this is great yeah man i'm
telling you creative tenacity i love the
phrase i'm so proud of you guys thank
you how's it feel to be free
what's your phrase it's amazing it's
great um no what's that word remember
the word relief release release a lot of
release yes
yeah that's a good word too
creative tenacity and relief the themes
of the story i love it well done you
guys all right tim and michelle from
omaha nebraska we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that is the next
uh
chapter in your story for you to be one
of these baby steps millionaires we've
been talking about this hour and of
course another copy of the total money
makeover for you to give to somebody
because that's where your whole journey
started and that'll be perfect for you
you can pay it forward well done tim and
michelle omaha nebraska 112 000 paid off
in four years and eight months
84 to 95 000 income while using creative
tenacity count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
how they do it omaha ladies and
gentlemen
there's some tenacity right there whoa
i love it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show george campbell is my
co-host today ramsey personality host of
the very popular podcast called the fine
print
on ramsey networks be sure and tune in
this week's uh version
is all about christmas spending and you
will get some real insights sandy's with
us in annapolis maryland hi sandy
hi thank you so much for taking my call
my honor how can we help
um so we started off doing the baby
steps um many years ago and that of
course got easier and easier as my
husband's income grew as his business
grew
and we are now 100
debt free
including owning our own form
congratulations well done
thank you so much i really appreciate it
though the only thing is we haven't
moved on to
uh meeting with a smart investor pro yet
because coveted and my daughter's immuno
compromised and i just have been trying
to stay away from
you know offices and things like that so
we we do have money just sitting in the
bank not doing anything
um and
that's honestly okay with me because i'm
really unhappy living where we are um
there's no internet i homeschool my kids
everything's at least 45 minutes away
including a decent grocery store
any of their
home school events are really like 45
minutes away
and i would really like how are you
doing homeschooling events if you're not
seeing people
well like if they have um swimming
lessons um
we have just
well we set it up so that it's private
with just the instructor oh um anything
like um we also do small classes
i don't be mean or anything but if a
swim instructor is safe so is the smart
vester pro
yeah you know this is just we just
started again like and so that is on my
list of things to do that we just picked
up again this year so you just can't be
selective about who carries the disease
that's not up to you
oh no no okay it wasn't at all last year
we stayed out of everything and it was
last year that we were ready oh last
year he's a smart investor
yeah so it was just i've just been
really busy and yeah we if you can get
the swim lessons honey you can get to
see an investment investment and they do
it over zoom now too so that's you know
you could easily meet virtually and talk
with them still and have that
conversation okay i'll stop i'll stop
being on you what's your question
darling
so i want to move and um so that we can
be some place um
where
it's not so hard um like we have
internet um we have
like i had to come outside to call you
um so
what will the farm sell for
i think it'll sell for about 6.50
but the problem is is that we really
need to buy something first
and then
move because the kids have horses and
stuff and we have we still have to
finish our kitchen and our master
bathroom here at this farm
before we can put it on the market and
it's kind of hard when you've got three
kids to do we've been the house has been
under construction since we bought it
and how did you buy it
we bought it about eight years ago
you have a construction project for
that's gone on for eight years
well like each thing like we've done the
floor we've done the um other bathrooms
the bedrooms
you have plenty of money why have you
not gotten this done
because my husband doesn't want to spend
any money he
he will only do the things by himself
and
um
he won't hire anyone to do it how much
money is in your bank account yes
in my bank account is 520 000
okay
here's what you would do if you were
wise and i don't know if i can talk you
all into doing this or not
if you were wise you would take some of
that freaking money that you have
hoarded in that bank account and you
would finish this construction project
that has gone on so long it's like noah
building the ark
you need to get this done
and then you need to get this house on
the market and you need to sell it and
when you sell it you need to take your
1 million 100 000 that you will have in
your pocket and go buy you something
yes
okay
i don't even need to buy something that
big i i you don't need to buy anything
until you get this construction project
done and this farm sold
okay now ready set go
get it get it okay so taking a mortgage
on a new place isn't an option then no
you have 500 000 in your checking
account you're not taking out a mortgage
well see my husband is only willing to
move if we spend less than the 520
thousand dollars i like him
to move he played to move into a less
rural area darling listen here's the
deal if you want more than you have in
your checking if you want to spend more
than you have in your checking on the
move you and your hus your husband and i
are in agreement on one thing and one
thing only and that is the farm must
pre-sale to do that but you cannot do
you have drugged this out forever
it's got to get over
it's got to get over i'm hearing a lot
of well here's the thing
well you don't dave you got to
understand my husband he wants to do it
this way you all got to get on the same
page and start to make some moves yeah
task orientation here it's like molasses
yeah task orientation we need to decide
on what the project is what the elements
of the project are and then get it
get after it y'all are just wandering
generalities
and you gotta just you know i don't care
if you want to buy a 400 or a 500 000
house with this 500 000 cash
that's fine go buy you one that's okay
i don't recommend that though because i
think you will have another eight years
working on this stupid farm
and i don't think your husband wants to
move at all i think that's the other
problem he's he's figuring out a way to
sabotage this because he likes that drag
it out he likes the farm you like a good
farm dave i like a good farm i don't
like 45 minutes to nothing that's okay
that kind of commute is for people in
other worlds other than mine but yeah no
i i just but oh man yeah i
here's the thing you guys have done an
amazing job being frugal and saving up a
big pile of money
don't mess this up by
not having enough task orientation to
properly follow through on the different
elements of your situation
so whatever you want to end up you need
to properly follow through
snappy
which is not what you've been doing uh
in order to get the best situation for
all of you so good question open phones
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
so
uh
let me be real clear so that some of you
that don't have anything to do are i'll
help you with your twitter account okay
um
you don't have enough to do so you want
to be a troll okay you giving them free
tweets here yeah i was not picking on
her for having
wanting to be separated from people
doing due to having a daughter with an
immune
disorder i completely agree with that
decision as a matter of fact
but you cannot choose between swim
instructors and financial advisors both
are as app one is app to carry covet as
the other
and so you you cannot use that excuse
for kicking the can down the road
um if you're gonna if you're gonna say
we're not seeing any humans that means
any
humans including homeschool humans
they're they qualify as humans
and so uh and one is this app to carry
covet as another
so i if that's your concern and that's
what you're doing you have to be
consistent in your critical thinking
skills that's all i'm asking
and uh so i'm not picking on the poor
lady with her daughter with an immune
disorder i completely agree with her as
a matter of fact until we got to we're
being selective about which humans we
can be around because some humans are
safe and some aren't
this is one of the things some of you
covered people drive me nuts with your
inconsistency in your logic
just
blows my brains out it's unbelievable
so
there's a lot there there's a lot in
that call i'm still unpacking it in my
head
not going on
but they're doing great financially
that's the amazing million one net worth
they're millionaires but they're really
good at saving up money but they haven't
made a plan for it you know that's it
planning is
there is a
correlation between those that get money
and keep it it's not just from frugality
frugality plus a plan is the only way
you keep it
and this this uh that's what i'm picking
on her about to get them get them up on
the road and let's get on the road don't
run through the ditch yeah get up on the
road run down the road run down a plan
of some kind you're right george that's
a good observation
[Music]
okay
good hour george fun times there we go
[Music]
james childs is our producer kelly
daniels our associate producer i'm dave
ramsey your host
[Music]
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where that is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five exciting times around
here at ramsey the borrowed future
podcast is exploding it is uh being
shown everywhere and uh podcasts
borrowed future documentaries we do have
both we have a podcast but documentaries
running through my head and the fine
print podcast is what i was trying to
get both of them in my head because your
your podcast the fine print is doing
extremely well as usual
and uh lots of things going on now the
borrowed future documentary you can see
it at apple tv at amazon prime and at
google play and at borrowed future dot
com and it's just like any other
documentary you can rent it watch it it
is
it's uh en enthralling if you're a
teacher if you go to borrowed future.com
i want to show it to your class we will
let you watch it for free
no charge
but uh tens of thousands of people now
over a hundred thousand people have
viewed this already and it's just been
out a few weeks it's already a big hit
and uh one of the things that we address
in borrowed future of course it's how
student loans are killing the american
dream we are not against education
some people mad about the student loan
mess are saying all four-year degrees
are worthless they're not
you can make more
than a lot of four-year degrees
as a diesel mechanic or a welder
you can make more than most lawyers as a
plumber
but all four-year degrees aren't useless
i have a four-year degree all three of
my kids have a four-year degree my hope
is that my grandchildren will also study
and become academically proficient the
problem is not four-year degrees the
problem is that higher education in some
cases and some people about higher
education have lost your freaking minds
and you are studying nuanced ridiculous
things that have no use in the
marketplace and you're paying a hundred
or two hundred thousand dollars for the
privilege of getting a master's degree
in left-handed puppetry
and it's just stupid
it's just stupid
so uh this uh free op how do you say
this i think it's just free up free
reopp dot org yeah they just did a full
comprehensive rate of return analysis on
college and it's called is
college worth it and it's from
freeop.org
f r e one e
o p p
so this report assesses the economic
value of nearly thirty thousand
bachelor's degree programs at seventeen
hundred seventy five colleges and
universities across the united states
very interesting detailed study on this
four in five engineering programs have
an roi above 500 000
wow you get a degree in engineering you
will make your money back and make an
extra 500 000 over your life at least
as a result
of having done this but
what was the number was it one in 16
what was the 16 number 16 have a
negative roi of all programs so almost
one in five
of all not engineering of all degrees
so when you get this degree in you pay
too much for it
at some kind of a famous school
because you wanted to go to a famous
school
or you study something that's just dumb
you're just dumb for getting a degree in
that
it's kind of weird that we're dumb about
education but we are and that's just
dumb to get a degree in this nuanced bb
stacking underwater bb stacking i've got
a master's degree in that you know i've
got a master's degree in czechoslovakian
medieval art that's as an roi you're not
going to make money on this dude this is
going to be a long there's only one
thing you can do with that become a
professor of czechoslovakian art that's
all you can do there's no jobs for that
except it's starbucks that's it
and so you're going to be a barista
that's what you're going to be and
there's no roi on your czechoslovakian
medieval art degree
so this is the thing like
is crazy
yeah and it goes on to say here and this
is no shocker that the bachelor's degree
programs like engineering computer
science uh economics nursing they do
have a positive roi but when you start
to go into art music philosophy religion
psychology it says students can be
financially worse off than if they'd
never gone to college at all
and so that scares me and a lot of
people are they're not thinking about
college choice and they're not thinking
about the roi of their degree and we
talk about how we're not against
education we just want the education to
match the goals so if you want to be a
nurse yes you got to go to school but if
you want to go into art unless you want
to be an art teacher you may not need to
go get a four-year degree at the ivy
league school
yeah and uh
after accounting for the risk of
dropping out roi for the median
bachelor's degree
drops to 129 000 on average that's the
median over a quarter of the programs
have a negative roi elite schools like
caltech and penn dominate the list of
the highest roi programs but attending
an elite school is not a golden ticket
some ivy league degrees have negative
roi and let me just tell you it's hard
to get an roi when you pay 200 000 for a
bachelor's degree
i don't care what it's in
it's hard to get a return on that
investment and versus if you have paid
60 000 for that same degree from a state
school you would have gotten the same
freaking job by the way
the same exact
job
if you got you know a degree in i.t
security four-year degree in information
systems specialization in i.t security
excellent degree field you got a degree
in supply chain oh my god obviously we
need some of those people working right
now and so um you know you got a degree
in that that's a big time job i mean
most of those jobs people are coming out
state school making 85 000 bucks right
now with an undergrad
no no masters okay and that's a
legitimate roi and you paid 60 000 bucks
for that or less for that degree but if
you want to go freaking over to some ivy
league and pay two and a quarter for
that it doesn't roi it's quick and and
even when it does it's not as good
obviously because you overpaid for the
virtually the same education yeah i
almost fell into that trap i almost went
to film school and it cost 200 grand for
four years and i didn't even know about
ramsay and i thought this doesn't sound
like a good idea i don't know that i'm
going to be the next big director so
maybe i shouldn't spend 200 grand on
film school wow so there's a lot of
mistakes people are making and it all
comes down to parents guidance
counselors the college industry there's
so much pressure that these 17 18 year
olds are feeling to make the biggest
financial decision of their life well
and
across the culture we've lied to them
that you have to get a college degree to
succeed a not true
b
the implication is is that getting a
college degree in something stupid
is okay
it's not okay
c going to any stupid school and
overpaying is okay that's not okay
either
so get a degree that you don't pay a lot
for in something that causes you to
actually go into the marketplace and win
boom
you know but i mean the meme that's
going around i saw it the other day on
instagram with the one time a month i'm
on there um said uh
you know here's jim the philosophy major
uh who hasn't had a job in
two years and he lives in his mother's
basement or he lives in his whatever and
here's joe
who jim makes fun of because he doesn't
have a college degree making 85 000 a
year as a lineman he's cutting off jim's
electricity right now so that's the meme
that's a good meme so that you know
that's that's it that's what's going on
so check it out borrowed future.com
make sure your teens are watching this
degrees and knowledge are important
doing them stupid would be a bad idea
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
first major trade book i've done in
eight years is on sale pre-sale starting
today it's called baby steps
millionaires how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
it'll actually arrive at your house on
january the 11th if you pre-order you
get a hundred dollars worth of bonus
items including baby steps millionaires
audiobook and e-book yes i read the
audiobook legacy journey audiobook and
e-book yes i read the audiobook
baby steps millionaires live stream and
the ramsey smart tax filing for your
income tax and ramsey plus 30 day free
trial for that
all of this is over 100 worth of goodies
included in your purchase for the book
we'll send you on out the legacy journey
audiobook and ebook so you'll have it
immediately
and that'll get you started on this
whole subject and then we'll get you
baby steps over in the first week of
january so uh all of that at
ramseysolutions.com if you want all
those pre-order items just jump on our
website and purchase it as quickly as
you can george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today taylor's
in fort worth texas hey taylor what's up
how are you doing sarah i'm doing well
good how can we help
yes sir so my wife and i have about 170
000 dollars in student loan debt
and we are considering moving about five
hours away for another job
um to try to uh
get more
intense of getting out of this debt
and i just wanted to know your opinion
on if it would be a wise decision or not
so what are these jobs what are you
moving from and to
um i would be moving from where i am now
to doing the same job
i'm a nurse anesthetist
and i'll be doing the exact same job
just a different location so what were
you making and what will you be making
um it's about i was making 150 and just
the base raise would be
[Music]
about 190 with the potential to go up to
about 290 um depending on how much
overtime i'd like to work wow there's a
lot of upside here
and as far as moving are you're married
yeah okay and how does your wife feel
about this
the move um so we have a four-month-old
she's currently staying home with her
right now and
um she's just willing to do whatever for
us to
just tackle this debt and get out of
debt even sooner so that we can
um you know eventually get into a house
and start saving for retirement and all
the
sequential steps of the baby steps
you're asking the question of whether
you should move why would you not do
this
well the the pros definitely are
the the pay raise um
and you know the dfw area is a good
place to be and
another pro is that we do have some
family over there that would help
um the con would obviously just be
packing everything up and moving
i'm also uh in the reserves and i also
have a drill here once a month
um so that would just be another little
roadblock um and those are kind of the
things that are holding me up
you're moving to dfw
i thought you were in fort worth
yes sir i'm in fort worth we would be
moving five hours away in another city
in texas where
uh lubbock
okay
all right so lubbock pays
a hundred thousand dollars a year more
than you're making now in dfw
for nurse anesthetist
if i did um some overtime
i could potentially exceed greater than
100. but why does lubbock pay a hundred
thousand dollars more than dfw that's
not logical
they are um
they sort staff
and get better for help
yes sir and bfw is very attractive
for families and people wanting to move
here so
the the supply for people wanting to be
here is a lot greater than the demand
logical okay
so the the downside is just packing up
and moving no one likes doing that but
there's not a lot of downside it sounds
like you said you have family in lubbock
are you saying you have a family in fort
worth
uh so i have one family member here in
fort worth um and my wife's majority of
her family are in lubbock okay
it sounds like i'm doing this move
and here's the thing
no one said you had to stay 20 years
you go over there for five years get the
mess cleaned up lay yourself a big nest
egg and then decide what you want to do
you may the supply demand curve may
shift again and you may be able to move
into a larger town if you want to move
back to a dfw type situation out of
lubbock if you want a different
lifestyle than small town because
lubbock's obviously a small town
lifestyle
yes sir and so um you know it's how you
want to live i don't care how you want
to live
um i got a buddy of mine from lubbock
and it's so flat there he says you can
watch your dog run away for three days
and so um
you know but the uh uh uh you know it's
a wonderful town i've been there a bunch
of times but uh so you just decide what
you want to do how you guys want to live
but i don't think there's anything wrong
with at your age and your stage of
career in the first five years of your
child's life being near the kid's
grandparents and mom her mom and dad and
whatever and that kind of stuff that's
all that's all positives i think it
takes the pressure off of the decision
if you say it might not be permanent
it might be a five-year thing
and then if you choose to stay that's
okay but if you get over there miserable
you can always move because the
beautiful thing about the career field
that you chose is it has a wonderful roi
yeah unlike we were talking about in the
first segment i mean nurse anesthetist
is ding ding do you're the money he can
make
and i'm a little surprised he's not
making better than that at dfw
uh but that's
because it's just a great income
producer man that that one
yeah they make more in a lot of docks
so uh
good good good choice but yeah i i don't
you know and here's the other thing i
you could look for yet another option
what's that is there something in dfw
that pays more
decent maybe it's just the hospital
group you're with
or is there something if you went to
mexico between lubbock and uh in size
and dfw how about san antonio
you know and move down us you know in
between i mean dallas is a major you
know top 20 cities san antonio's not
yeah and so you can move maybe maybe
there's a middle ground i don't know but
the good news is families near i i'm
doing it for a while
i think yeah it's a reversible decision
and i mean he's got a great income and
it's 170k in debt either way you're
gonna pay it off in two years or two and
a half years and so to me is it worth
the move for that now with the upside of
overtime and really stacking up some
money and getting yourself in a great
financial position i'm doing that if it
means driving five hours and packing up
my stuff and the baby yeah packing up
your stuff's not a thing man you ain't
got that much stuff
so
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five melissa's in san
diego hi melissa welcome to the ramsay
show
hey um thanks for just my call sure how
can we help
hey there um i'm a long time listener
but i've actually never heard this
question answered over the air um
so i am 70 grand in debt i'm 28 years
old
i have 55 grand in student loans
i'm probably a very common theme on that
documentary you guys did on borrowed
futures
and i am working on my debt snowball in
december i'm actually going to be
get a decent pay raise and i plan on
putting all of that into paying down
debt way to go and i'm wondering thank
you and i'm wondering how to go about
paying down my student loans because
when i look up how to do the student
loans i actually see eight different
student loans because it's a multiple
year degree
so it's student loans a through h and
they're all different amounts yeah so
we're going to line those up in the debt
snowball are you saying do those count
as eight different debts
yes yes so just line those up from
smallest to largest we're ignoring the
interest rate completely and that way
you're gonna feel the progress when you
knock one out you're gonna free up a
payment you're gonna feel that progress
you're gonna knock the second one out
and you're gonna work your way through i
wouldn't treat it as one giant loan we
want you to feel the progress here we
want you to feel the pain too and you're
going to get through this thing pretty
quickly with this race so just keep
following the baby steps does that
answer the question
yes yeah that's what you do what's the
other 15 000 in debt
so 12k is in the car and three grand is
in credit cards okay so that three grand
is going to be interspersed somewhere in
those student loans
in that debt snowball and the 12k is
probably at the bottom is probably your
largest debt then is my guess if you've
got eight into 55 maybe not you might
have a student loan bigger than 12
but um
but those cars towards the bottom and
that credit card is probably towards the
top
and will be interspersed but yes
separate the eight george is exactly
right that way you feel the progress
because that's what you want you want
this sense of traction human beings all
of us psychologically yearn to have
observable progress in our lives that's
why the snowball works this is the
ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsey show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five joe's in fort dodge iowa hi joe how
are you
pretty well how are you doing dave
better than i deserve how can we help
sir
yeah so i'm calling in about
maybe some interviewing tips
specifically i'm in the utility industry
as an electrical designer
and i've been doing it about eight years
i'm aspiring to be a supervisor and it
seems as though
every time
i interview i'm when i'm turned down
they'll say something to the effect of
um you don't have any supervisory
experience
so so then i go from there
you know my my engineering manager and
engineering supervisor are supportive
and know i do a really good job but
that's the problem i keep running into
is i just keep being told i don't have
any supervisory experience but i
really don't have that opportunity per
se in the position i'm in now
[Music]
i would um
preemptively strike on that then
okay
okay and so meaning early in the
conversation i'm just going to say out
loud
i you probably notice on my resume i
don't have supervisory experience
but in this case it won't matter at all
because what i do know is how to add
value to other people and how to serve
and really the essence of leadership is
service
right
or something like that that's real pithy
like that that was pretty cool
that was really good dave i'm impressed
you got the job
so but i mean if you preemptively strike
and you say and you give some indication
you understand what leadership looks
like
my job as a leader is not to boss people
around
my job as a leader would be to add value
to the people that i'm leading my job
would be to serve them and enable them
to do their jobs better and so the
essence of leadership is really service
and so
uh a servant leader is the only real
leader everyone else is just a boss if
you're looking for somebody to be a boss
i really can't help you but if you want
somebody to lead i do have the personal
character and skills to do that even
though i've not been in the role
before they before it even enters their
mind you've already busted their head
open right
right
that's the only thing i don't do jordan
got a suggestion what was the
conversation like when they when they
said well you don't have supervisory
experience what was your response
um i guess i really didn't have uh a
follow-up to that other than just i'll
you know just keep trying to do what i
can and i that was the turn down though
that wasn't in the interview that's when
they called and said you don't get the
job because i'm surprised it didn't come
up in the interview
how was that not a conversation oh
they're godless oh man
is there a position there that you would
want where you could work your way up in
that company
to a supervisor level that's what that
that's what i'm trying to do actually so
where i'm at now i'm a as i mentioned
electrical designer for our lineman
and the position would be um for
substation so it's it's different but
it's at the company
um should be working with a different
group altogether big learning curve but
i wouldn't be bothered by it at all
actually excited to and and really what
actually what happened is that they
turned turned me down maybe about a
month ago
and the person that they accept it or
that they gave the position to they
turned that down as well so now it's
posted again and so so i'm just trying
to get ready to hopefully get us another
interview
um
that you know just
yeah so okay what i want you to do is
when you get off i want you to go to uh
just jump on amazon well amazon's not
delivering real well right now um
let me think um
yeah i'll just send you one we've got a
special edition of this the book is uh
21 irrefutable laws of leadership by
john maxwell
and uh and i'll send you a copy of that
as a gift all right and i want you to
read that book like in the next 48 hours
as soon as you get it
sure
and what you what you're looking for
are
tweet tweetable
one-liners
that you can drop all in this
interview as an indication you have a
clue about leadership
sure
and uh and you and then you just bring
it up again preemptively
and say you can see you know and matter
of fact i've applied for jobs like this
here in the past and didn't get them and
the turndown was i didn't have
experience uh but you know what you
don't need experience to love people
you don't need experience to lead people
all you do is have character
and actually care about someone else and
not be self-centered
be other centered exactly and that's how
you lead that's how high quality
world-class leaders lead
they're they're not arrogant jerks
they're not a boss with a cattle prod
you know that's not what they're doing
right and so uh they're actually
standing over going come this way this
is where we're all going together let's
all go together matter of fact when we
get there there's going to be skittles
and rainbows so let's go boys and girls
come on let's go and you know this is
what we're talking about we're leading
we're not pushing
leaders are pulling bosses are pushy
so uh that kind of stuff so i'll send
you maxwell's book because if john's a
friend of mine we did a a ramsey
licensed version of it i wrote the
forward in our version i'll send you a
copy of it um that's his that's his best
seller anything john maxwell wrote on
leadership will help you but that's his
best seller ever you might if you want
to get a second one probably 360 degree
leader you think george yeah and ken
coleman's got a great interview guide on
his site that's free oh it's a great
resource on the interview side so on the
leadership side definitely show them
that you're engaging in learning about
leadership and that you're very
interested in this but on the other side
the interview guide might help you just
in the conversational pieces along the
way yeah that's that's gold that's
called jump on king coleman's site get
anything he's got too
so um okay
yeah those things but but for sure
maxwell's probably doing more on
the art
of leadership
than anybody else out there uh
most of my writing on leadership and the
entree leadership stuff is more the
science meaning the tactical the
hand-to-hand combat to what to do but
maxwell is very art
and is just uh he's the grandpa in the
space and again a good friend of mine
just a wonderful man but also a
wonderful writer on the subject of
course jim collins
is one of the better writers too in this
space but he's a researcher jim is on
like he did the book good to great uh so
right overall start reading some
leadership books overall
that's the moral of the story here but
but between now how to prep for the
the job interview is actually give some
indication you understand what
leadership is even though you've not
been in a technical form or form formal
role and if you've ever done leadership
off-site meaning you are
i don't know you're on the deacon board
of the church
or you serve as the uh
the treasurer at the local kiwanis club
i don't care what it is i mean anywhere
you've been in a leadership role of some
kind extracurricular activities so to
speak you're the captain of the softball
team i don't care i'd bring that up and
go and here's the lessons i learned when
i was doing that yeah and the right
person can be trained if that's a piece
of it but you know when i started here
dave i didn't have all of the experience
and checked every single box they just
want this guy's eager to learn he's
hungry humble smart we can teach him all
the practical skills yeah because
there's nothing boring leaders i mean
i've been to the hospital they always
say it's a boy it's a girl they never
say it's a leader you know they never do
that so leaders are grown
when i started i was a boss and now i'm
a world class leader i got over a
thousand team members
and i didn't say i was perfect i just
said i was world class leader and i am
really good at this and i spent a lot of
time a lot of energy learning and
growing into that and that's what
anybody has to do you're right george
hungry humble and smart to quote our
friend pat lincione which is another
great book to read by the way anything
he writes a lot of good book
book recommendations anything that pat
writes is worth reading in that space as
well so he's uh
uh
well i mean i guess i've written read
everything he's written too
i think i have oh his new one is good on
this um
the motive i think it's oh yeah that's
that's a newer one yeah i think that's
good for this subject i bring a stack of
books say here's here's my writing list
we started on books man i can sell some
books because i love books but the yeah
the motive is all about don't take a
leadership role so that you get to be
the boss take a leadership role because
you have the privilege of serving
we need more of that and if you had that
you're a real leader
probably not in the presidential
candidate but you're probably a real
leader
[Music]
oh
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well
christmas
this year it's in december if you hadn't
heard
don't let it sneak up on you baby
no hey for some of you what should be a
time of joy or tradition or togetherness
for some people christmas is just stress
how we going to pay for presents
grocery bills
even some travel how we going to do all
this all the other stuff man
it doesn't have to be that way
you can put together a plan for your
money and you can still do it by
christmas
you'll have the confidence
when everything else seems out of
control
we're gonna teach you a plan that will
change your life in financial peace
university we've taught almost 10
million people
in financial peace university how to get
out of debt
how to save money how to become wealthy
how to become a baby steps millionaire
like the new book
and that'll be outrageously generous
and you're going to put the plan into
practice with budgeting
with the premium version of every dollar
syncs up with your bank you can track
your spending you can finally see where
your money goes this thing called
money's had control of you now it's time
for you to get control of this thing
called money
you get financial peace university the
premium version of every dollar with a
ramsey plus membership
and if you want a free trial of a ramsey
plus membership just go to
ramseysolutions.com
ramsayplus
or when you go to rmzsolutions.com just
put in every dollar or put in
financial peace university put in any of
that
and there's no reason for you to have
stressed out life anymore particularly
stressed out christmas
supposed to be peace on earth
and it's just not
for a lot of people
and here's the thing
you can fix that
and we have shown more people how to fix
that
than anyone else
at ramsey
so ramsay plus a free trial
at ramseysolutions.com
and you will quickly see
what i'm talking about george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
kevin is in richmond virginia hi kevin
how are you
hi doing well how are you doing
gentlemen better than i deserve how can
we help
all right so i've been a dave ramsey
listener for probably a year going on
two years now
and after me and my wife's uh second
wedding this year thanks to kovit
we ended up sitting down talking about
our finances we were fresh out of
college all kinds of fun you know
college loan debt
bought a house
both have vehicles on loans and i i just
want to get a glass of the baby steps
you know we got through the first one of
the book got through the first one was
motivated and we just cannot seem to get
baby step two so i was wondering what
advice you can give somebody that's
struggling to stay on the grind of
getting past step two since that's
probably one of the hardest ones
so when you say you're struggling with
this is it are you not seeing progress
are you just not doing it
i would say a little bit of both um i'd
put the blame on myself saying that i'm
the one that's kind of the the rational
spender when i see a good deal i go
after it and that's my fault
um but you know i recognize it and i
want to do better by but
that's really the big struggle for me is
that when i get a little bit of debt i
see room and i try to fill it right back
up when i find a good deal
yeah my dad used to tell me when i was a
kid he'd say go clean the garage and i
said are you gonna help he said no i
thought of it
great he said recognizing the problem is
90 of solving it
yeah
and i've already went through and kind
of sold everything
that i didn't need everything that had a
value um within me and my wife's house
just to you know try to get some
motivation some extra room to start it
get the ball rolling yeah but then you
went out and spent everything at target
it did yes so it doesn't do any good
you're just spinning your wheels
so uh how old are you guys
uh i'm 24 my wife's 23. cool so what's
your household income
uh household income
i would say is around 90 000. good for
you what do you do for a living
uh
you'll laugh at this one i'm a finance
director cool no it's not unusual at all
man i had a finance degree and couldn't
add up my own budget
they don't teach us
hey they don't teach us that they teach
us corporate finance when we're getting
our degrees
they don't teach you anything about
personal finance so it's not unusual
and what's your wife do
my wife's a teacher good okay
and um how much debt do you have not
counting the house you bought
not counting the house
it's probably
around
i'd say a hundred thousand
what's that on
uh so student loans for me is seventy
five thousand for my wife is 36 000 she
got extremely uh lucky and blessed and
had some of her stuff forgiven
and then i have a truck at 25 000
and my wife has a car at 7 000 and then
all the credit card debt is me
at about 4 500.
okay i thought you said a hundred
thousand
uh what i'm sorry what did that add
yeah it ended up being a little more
than 100 150 yeah yeah okay
all right so here
um
in order to do your day job
you have to be more detailed than you've
been
on this subject
you have the intellectual capability to
be detailed
and to lay out a process and follow a
process
you have emotionally chosen not to do
that so far
an indication of that is i have a
hundred thousand dollars worth of debt
when actually you have about 150.
okay
yeah you following me
so yeah what you're gonna have to do is
rise up out of
the uh a little bit of hopelessness
and a little bit of immaturity
that you've described and say time for
me and my new wife
to be adults throw our shoulders back
because children do what feels good
adults devise a plan and follow it and i
want you to pretend like i just hired
you for two hundred thousand dollars a
year to fix this simple little mess you
have
because
in terms of mathematics it's a very
simple primitive mess there's not that
much to it the only problem with it is
the person in your mirror
make sense
oh yeah i agree with you this is all
behavior it's not intellect you don't
have an intellectual problem you're very
smart
there's no question about that yeah
kevin have you guys been through
financial peace university
uh we have not no well what i want to do
is gift you guys ramsay plus and that's
the membership that'll give you access
to financial peace university every
dollar our budgeting tool the premium
version and what i want you to do is
make a budget if you're not already it
sounds like you're probably not doing a
regular budget
and then go through financial peace
university with your wife sit down watch
all nine lessons and you got to get
intense man because right now i think we
care more than you do about getting out
of debt
and you got to care you've got to say i
want a different future for me
i got i got to poke at you enough to
piss you off
honey i need to get you mad in a good
way you know what i'm talking about like
like i like i'm the drill sergeant and
you're in boot camp
yeah that's for the and so george is
putting you in boot camp can you treat
it that way if we give it to you as a
free gift
i think i could yeah intellectually
decide i'm in boot camp i'm gonna get my
butt kicked here and i'm gonna do
everything exactly as these people say
i'm not gonna second-guess anything
because i'm the guy who made a mess not
the guy who cleaned it up but you're
about to be the guy that cleaned it up
if you'll follow this exactly what we
tell you to do
you're going to be out of debt in
100 debt-free in two years
other than your house
you may or may not sell the truck in
that process i'll leave that up to you
that truck's questionable but the rest
of it is just you're gonna have to get
after it and you know scratch and claw
and keep your butt out of target
that's the thing
so it's a danger zone yeah i mean you
don't you just i i hey i'm just like you
man this is how i learned this stuff
when i first started this stuff i
thought that when you went to sam's or
costco the reason they checked your
receipt on the way out was i thought it
was federal law you had to spend 200
bucks when you're in there
and i thought they were checking to make
sure i spent my 200 bucks oh you didn't
you got to go back in there and get some
more peanut butter dude get that five
gallons of peanut butter because you
hadn't spent your 200 bucks because you
i just went in there and buy crap
i mean this dopamine rush that you get
of just buying stuff
and those of us that are spenders we
understand that but you've got to get up
over the top of that
and say hey if i can get my act together
if i live like no one else later i can
live and give like no one else changes
everything turns out you can go broke
saving money
how's that for a deal everything's 100
off when you don't buy it
oh man george that's right i'm excited
to be a sergeant in this boot camp i've
never been a sergeant it's exciting
there you go just work on it
i can i can just see you yelling at
somebody i've got a great yell yeah i
bet
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host i almost called you joe camel
did you hear that it's happened before
it wouldn't be a first i'll take it that
would be a conic name that would be bad
that would be bad a little different
teaching teenagers to smoke cigarettes i
can't imagine you're doing that i don't
even know if teenagers know who joe
camel is it may have been not current
teenagers but people who used to be
teenagers do you you used to be one
it was a long time ago
oh my goodness open phones this hour as
we talk about your life and your money
that we can actually help you with
triple eight eight two five five
two two five jenny is in denver hi jenny
welcome to the ramsey show
hi guys great to talk to you my question
is
should i allow my 25 year old daughter
to use money that was intended for
college to pay off her credit card debt
so where where is this money parked
um it is in mutual funds and a brokerage
account um
that she
doesn't have access to even though she's
over 21 but
we've kind of kept that because we don't
think
she's ready for us how much credit card
debt is this
um she has about 8 000 in credit card
debt and 3 000 in a student loan that
she never took any classes for
oh
so she's already how much money how much
money is in this quote college fund
um it was given to her by a grandmother
and it's 130 000 total um my husband i
actually put in about 20 000 of it but
whose name is it in
it's under her name and it's not under a
529 or anything but that was the intent
when she was a baby
and she's already finished with college
my husband and i paid for her college
oh she did and you paid for it well good
for her
okay so um you're the custodian on the
account
um well not officially anymore but um
yeah they gave that they say
um they don't you don't think they can
handle it they might not know the
password etc
okay
so
you're basically keeping her money from
her to protect her from her is what
you're saying
i'm correct you haven't seen this okay
so what does she what behaviors are she
is she engaged in that
make you think she's not capable of
handling this
well um
she she's recently unemployed which is
why she asked us about it um because i
think
she's getting you know kind of stressed
out but anyway um she spends a lot of
money
um we've asked her to take your class
but she won't do it she won't
talk to us about
sitting down with us and doing a budget
she she's learned all this as a kid and
in high school or school taught your
class but
she just seems to
spend as fast as she can it seems
that's my concern is if you clean up the
8 000 with this fund she may just rack
up another 8 000. there's no lessons
learned here
that's my concern and you know yet she's
25 years old i'm not sure exactly
you know what what place i have him
yeah i mean
there's two sides to this equation right
now i mean there's a side where there's
a concerned mom
who doesn't want her daughter to blow
130 000 and look back and regret it uh
there's another side if she figures out
that money's there
uh and you don't give it to her
instantly
she's gonna sue your butt and win
this is not your money you don't legally
have control of it anymore
right you're just you're just you're
just trying to do a little
smoking mirrors here to keep your hands
off it so i mean you've got to balance
this a little bit between the fact that
um what you're doing is for her own good
uh but you're not going to get away with
it forever
correct yeah i know that it's not in a
trust
no
it's simply in her it's simply her bank
account and she doesn't have the
password
yes
i feel bad about that i do but
i kind of do but i kind of don't i'm
with you i'm kind i mean i love the fact
that you're trying to help her
uh but i don't know how much longer we
can babysit this child
um and not get yourself in trouble in
the process
okay so uh why do you think you guys
have been unable to persuade her to grow
up
um
she's
pretty hard headed and
has a lot of different value systems
than
she was brought up with and what her dad
and i have and i think she doesn't want
to listen to us
so you've really lost the ability to
have a reasonable dialogue
yes
um
i don't know how to answer this for sure
i'm trying to think about it live here
on the air with 22 million people
listening at the moment
while i'm hesitating and stumbling
because i i actually agree with both
sides of this equation
um
what would i do if i woke up in your
shoes
well number one i'd be crying a lot
because this is such a disappointing
horrible situation
number two i probably would have done
what you have done to this point i often
told my kids that you won't find this uh
uniform transfer to miners act account
if you're doing heroin or running around
and living on the back of a yacht like
you're some kind of a reality star you
just won't know it's there good luck
i'll never give it to you and i told
them that uh however we're down to four
years over time
that she is legally in control of this
account if she ever gets this
um
man you could get yourself in a mess
here
so i'm about ready to hand this i'm
about ready to hand this account to this
kid and just wash my hands
and go you know what
you are you are a mess and you're gonna
make a mess with this and i am disgusted
and i hate it because i think i'm doing
you harm and as your mom it makes me cry
but you know
you just don't have the values and
you're you're about to mess this up i
know you're going to and i'm i wish you
wouldn't i wish you'd go to financial
peace university i wish you'd grow up
and turn this in money that your
grandmother left you but she's going to
because your grandmother's going to be
in heaven shaking her head she's ashamed
of you and i'm i'm ashamed i'm ashamed
oh okay we're all we're all ashamed of
your behavior will she talk to her
grandmother
and say i'm sorry dave would she talk to
her grandmother
yeah she i mean not about that her
grandmother gave her five thousand
dollars last year to clean up the debt
and but will her grandmother knock her
noggin on her not gonna knock a knot on
her
yeah i can i could ask for that
she might hear she she's probably done
with you is what i it sounds like i'm
hearing
with you telling her what to do
but maybe granny can get away with it
because granny put most of this money in
there
you know another yeah i
uh
there's legal issues involved here
okay okay and then there's the moral
issue of whether you're gonna bring harm
to your child if i was the grandparent
i'd be asking you to transfer me the
uh password and i'd take the money back
and i would say get after it kiddo sue
me i ain't giving you nothing and i
would knock a knot on her if i was the
granddaddy
grandma yeah now mom and dad might be
different but good luck suing your
grandma oh i wouldn't do that
that that's that's a special place in
hell right there
oh my gosh
but uh yeah you got legal issues because
you guys put the money in her name
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this zip recruiter pitches
your profile to companies whose jobs
match your skills and experience if
someone from that company likes your
profile they can personally invite you
to apply for the job so if you're ready
for an easier job search check out
ziprecruiter sign up for free right now
at ziprecruiter.com ken that's
ziprecruiter.com slash ken sign up today
absolutely free and let zip recruiter
work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well folks we've got a new release for
you most people know me as the guy who's
done stupid with a lot of zeros on the
end
i made my first million dollars in my
20s
and then i lost it all because i was
stupid
then i became a millionaire again and
then a multi-millionaire and after three
decades of teaching other people to
handle money god's ways with common
sense
uh we've led literally tens of thousands
of people into becoming millionaires
using the baby steps
and so uh i haven't written a book in
eight years a major trade book anyway
and uh so i wrote one it's called baby
steps millionaires how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth and how you
can do it goes on sale today
if you buy a copy of it in pre-sale the
book will actually be
uh shipped it's only 20 the book will
actually be shipped january the 11th
and if you buy it in pre-sale you will
get the baby steps millionaires
audiobook which i just completed the
other day you won't get until january
and ebook the legacy journey audiobook
and ebook now
the baby steps millionaires live stream
event that we will do in january
the
ramsey smart tax for you to file your
taxes free
and a 30-day free trial of ramsay plus
so you can learn these baby steps and
how to become
a baby steps millionaire you get all of
this
at ramseysolutions.com
pre-order your baby steps millionaire
copy for 20 bucks and get all of those
goodies now and of course the book will
actually come
there and there you go youtubers uh the
book will actually come
in uh on in january on january the 11th
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings with
free samples free shipping and new
promos all the time you save all the
time i always use the promo code ramsey
hey listen if you want window blinds
this is a great american company i use
them personally i recommend blinds.com
today's question comes from jenna in
baton rouge my parents have always
emphasized how important it is to have a
good credit score my husband and i are
debt free other than our mortgage when
we pay that off we will not have
anything left to show up on our credit
report
i have to admit i'm dragging my feet on
paying off our home because i'm afraid
of how it will impact us in the future
should we slow down our payoff in order
to keep that debt open as long as we can
oh boy should we keep debt around to
avoid i don't want to pay money
so i have a credit score
there's there's real fear here
apparently they're afraid of how it will
impact them in the future well here's
the thing i know about credit scores you
only need one
if you want to take on debt
and even then you don't need one for a
mortgage so their question is should we
slow down our mortgage payoff so let's
say let's go the hypothetical route they
pay off the mortgage and their credit
score disappears after a little while
now you don't have a credit score
well do you plan on going to get a car
loan
and if you plan on going to get another
mortgage i don't know why you would but
you can do that manually underwritten
and no no score alone with no credit
scores you did that yeah i did that and
so there's an arrest you went to
churchill mortgage with no credit score
got a manually unwritten loan
and you're not far from paying off your
house now no
uh we didn't we're about to do it over
two years hesitating in order to have a
credit score i have no fear of having no
credit score and we didn't have one when
we got the house obviously we have one
now and it'll disappear i don't know
what my credit score is i don't care
because i don't plan on going into debt
and so the irrational fear is is coming
in because they think how am i going to
live my financial life without a score
well here's the here's the problem jenna
you actually believe
that you have prospered because of your
credit score because your parents taught
you that
and your parents were wrong
and that belief that you have prospered
because of your credit score is what's
holding you is what's messing you up
here because that belief is a lie you
you're believing a lie
okay no one is prospered
because of their credit score
the credit score is built on the fact
that you borrowed money
paid it back on time
and you grew your credit score why did
you do that so that you could borrow
money and pay it back on time so that
you grow your credit score why did you
do that so that you could borrow money
so that you can pay it back on groundhog
day and so yeah i mean this is a dog
chasing its freaking tail here and you
guys are just going in circles and all
you're doing is keeping the bank open
and not jenna open
and so jenna this is about what makes
you prosperous
and by the way your credit score is not
a measure of your prosperity it is not a
measure of your net worth it's not a
measure of your income as a matter of
fact it doesn't take any of those things
into consideration
the only thing your credit score takes
into consideration the algorithm that
builds it is 100 based on how much you
play kissy face with debt
that's all it is
and so you know the all of your fear all
of your hesitation is based on you
believing a lie and the lie is that
credit scores cause prosperity
and they do not they merely measure
how much you've been playing kissy face
with the bank
how much interaction you've had with
debt
they merely measure that and the only
thing they give you is the ability to
borrow again and more
which does not cause prosperity it
causes the opposite it causes prosperity
for the freaking bank
stop it pay off your stinking house
we did an episode uh on the fine print
all about this it's called the dirty
truth behind your credit score you can
check it out uh wherever you find your
podcast and we we did this dave we went
through and we talked to
uh someone at churchill and they
explained to us the manual underwritten
process we called apartments and found
out you can rent without a credit score
i've i just rented a car and i rented
hotels just this past week without a
credit score with a debit card and so
these things can be done but there's
this myth out there that i'm not going
to be able to move in my financial life
i can't breathe if i don't have that
good credit score to show everyone yeah
and it is mythology
all right i got to go back to that last
call before the break oh yeah
i'm still swimming in that
so the mom calls you got a 25-year-old
daughter this money is in the daughter's
name mom has the passcode
there's 130 000 in their mom put in 20
000 grandma put in 110 000. it was
earmarked for the kid to go to college
the parents instead paid for the college
the daughter however has gone
off the rails
doesn't want to have anything to do with
her parents values
doesn't want to work
uh ha is not working
uh is irresponsible
and so getting this hundred and thirty
thousand dollars as a gift from her
grandmother and her parents is not going
to be a blessing to her it's going to
bring harm to her however it is legally
her money technically it is in her name
her grandmother put it in her name and
her parents put it in her name
and so um
there's really two options here one is
follow the law
and give the kid the money
and she's gonna blow it and screw up her
life
and we're all gonna be pissed at her and
she's even gonna be pissed herself later
it's gonna be a prodigal son moment like
you said at the break she's gonna you
know have to find her way to the pigs
uh the other option
is to not give it to her and you could
have all kinds of trouble from her
she finds some jack leg lawyer and sues
everybody involved um
so
i i didn't want the mom to have that
liability in order to protect this kid
who's
misbehaving
the only thing i could come up with is
to put is for the grandmother to take
control the situation put the money back
in her checking account and just um
tell the granddaughter good luck with
this yeah it's my money to start with i
just took it back you want to fight me
on that we'll talk about it in court
your grandma's going to lose
yeah if she goes to court
because it was in the daughter's name
because she she took she took her money
that wasn't rightfully hers well she she
gifted it to her to start with then she
took it back
and so you might actually get away with
it if you had a judge with a sense of
humor but legally speaking the money has
been the title of the money has been
transferred i'm not a lawyer but that's
what happened that's the the downside of
putting money in your kid's name your
kid could go off the rails
and they went off the rails i don't know
that's a risk you choose willing to take
but the question was should i pay off
the eight thousand dollars of credit
cards no she racked up no
and the truth is it's just enabling at
that point no you either give her the
whole money and let her pay it off
or you tell grandma to clean out the
account put it in grandma's checking
account if grandma's willing to bow up
and fight the kid but grandma just gave
her five thousand dollars the other day
so i don't know if grandma's willing to
fight her or not yeah she sounds like
i'm a grandpa i'd be ready to fight her
i'd be willing to pay to see that fight
i'd be going good luck baby child
i love you i love you so much i will
bite you
that's true love
that would be it
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today travis and ashley are with
us on the debt-free stage in the lobby
of ramsey solutions what's up guys hey
how are you doing dave george good to
have you brother so uh how much uh where
do you guys live we're from fayetteville
arkansas cool and how much data have you
paid off 195
236 dollars yep and how long did this
take right at six years good for you and
your range of income during that time
started at 76 000 and now we're just
north of 160. yeah excellent what do
y'all do for a living
so i'm a i started as a graphic designer
at the beginning of this and now i'm a
creative marketing manager okay and i'm
an accountant all right very good so six
years a hundred and ninety five thousand
i'm gonna guess and say maybe you paid
off your house you're right yeah we did
looking at weird people the weirdest set
free
completely
wow good for you well done what's the
house worth uh probably about 250 now
excellent very cool good for you guys
so uh tell us the story what happened
six years ago how'd you get plugged into
ramsey and what are you doing so
actually i had a professor that told me
that before you start applying to jobs
you should google your own name so you
can figure out what the employer's gonna
see
and whenever i did this i found out that
my grandparents had actually filed for
bankruptcy
and i didn't know that and my
grandfather is senior i'm the third
and i oh
my
goodness so whenever i did this um
it really made me go well i did what
every 21 year old would do and go how do
i get rich quick so i started googling
it because i'm like i never want this to
happen again
and sure enough your video was there
and uh you said oh get rich quick
i said don't get rich
quick
you said the best way to get rich quick
is to get rich slow
and uh
i skipped that class that day because i
did about an hour before the assignment
was due and from there we just started
instantly and never looked back yeah
this was about the time we started
dating and he pretty much was like hey
i'm on this journey
um do you want to come along for the
ride and i was like
yep let's do it because i think we both
have really big dreams and it was a
vital part of being together and going
on this journey so was this all mortgage
uh actually it was 45 000 of student
loans and the rest was mortgage wow my
student loan's not his so i was of
course like okay let's go on this
journey and he's like okay let's tackle
your student
so that became the first one in the dead
snowball yes that's right wow and you
guys just plowed right on through to the
mortgage yeah we did i mean from the
time we bought the house the mission was
to pay it off
so that's incredible
so what were the tactical things that
you guys were doing what were the
sacrifices along the journey well
he hates when i tell this story but the
first year i'll just start with i really
wanted an autumn wreath for the front
door and that's what started it all i
didn't get that autumn wreath and then
it turned into
the next big decision the next big
decision and we just consistently
started saying no
to
material things or things that we
couldn't
have right then because we couldn't
afford them and we just went down that
path one decision after another and just
stayed consistent with that george this
is a common thread that when you give up
the autumn wreath
that's it that's when you know you're
going to be okay the autumn wreath
you're kidding ten dollars
this is this was a breakdown right i
mean a meltdown over the i mean it's not
even a christmas wreath it's an autumn
wreath it was a fall wreath i did not
get to have a fall wreath on my door and
you know i'm 61. i've still never had
one who knew i didn't know that was a
thing they're big in arkansas yeah well
i'll probably get home with sharon's
probably got one hanging on the door by
the time i get there now
yeah that's hilarious oh man the autumn
it's the autumn wreath yeah there has to
be this defining thing that was at the
moment that's fabulous i really like
that because you can remember this
silly little thing and you go that's
when it turned that was how we knew we
were committed and all in and we were
going to do whatever it took and you
know we were going to say no to the now
so we could say yes later
you know when the kids are low it's hard
to get a babysitter so we finally get a
babysitter we finally are going out to
eat
and
we left and we were a mile and a half
from home i can show you exactly the
traffic light we were sitting at and i
forgot the stupid food envelope oh
and i said well there's an atm right
there across the street we can just go
through get that we'll put the money
back when we get back to the thing and
uh as i'm pulling across that street
towards that atm i said nope
not doing that
and we turned around that parking lot
drove back home
and something about that action
that was it that was the day it was done
wow we're gonna do this this way we're
gonna do this envelope system we're not
gonna screw around with this we're not
going to cheat and that's what the
autumn wreath is that's so cool i love
that
that is awesome so do you have the
autumn wreath up now oh you believe i
have an autumn wreath or christmas
series i have a wreath for every season
now let's get the wreath collection now
one for each month a september october
wreath oh i love that this is so great
yeah this is because i got to tell you
that's that's important that you
recognize that because that gives you
the tools then to go do anything else
you want to do from this point so now
that you're 100 debt-free what's your
first big wonderful thing you're gonna
do um honestly we have two horrible cars
so we're actually planning on upgrading
both of those very yeah you need to you
need to yeah so that that's really next
and then honestly we want to come out
here and celebrate and
you know
future home future kids we don't have
kids so we're just starting to save for
the future
wow very good good for y'all i'm so
proud of you well done all right when
somebody asks how do you how old are you
28 years old yes both paid four houses
worth 250 000 yes you have a dime owed
anywhere in the world no
and when someone says how do you do that
what do you tell them the secret to
getting out of debt is consistency
honestly that's what it is you have to
sit down every month
he'll say the budget but i think that
goes with consistency it's just sitting
down every month together and knowing
what the end goal is going to be why
you're doing it
where you're going and you're going to
have good months bad months but as long
as you both know where you're going and
what the goal is i think that's the big
thing is that's how you stay gazelle
intense is you know what you're working
towards wow i'm just curious because a
lot of people they have their student
loan debt and they tackle that and
that's wonderful but what made you guys
go we want to do something so big and so
bold at 28 years old we're gonna pay off
our house well we knew our goals for
long term were not normal and we knew if
we wanted to get where we wanted to go
we were gonna have to do something
radical and when we really sat down and
look at it
this was just the kind of thing we were
after yeah so at 22 you guys said we
want a long-term vision we don't this is
not a two-year thing this is a 10-year
thing a 15-year thing what do we want to
be doing at 30 yes that's it's a
lifelong thing i joke with people at my
work i'm like we're going to retire at
35 if we can and we're just gonna you
know live this amazing life and everyone
always laughs but i i think we're both
just that weird where we're like you
know we really want to do something that
not the average person is going to do
yeah yeah you're on track to do that so
proud of y'all
very very well done very well done who
was your biggest cheerleader outside the
two of you i i would say honestly we had
some smart investor pros that helped us
josh melissa thank you guys so much
our friends andrew and megan they're on
the journey too right now so
they did a great job and then honestly
we took fpu and having the whole group
together was just awesome jen and
candace thank you so much um for leading
financial peace university yes and our
family i mean our family they didn't
understand what we were doing a lot of
times and they didn't understand
you know why we were doing it but they
knew they trusted us and they just let
us do our thing so yeah and it was a big
deal to us and it was important so they
were super supportive
your grandpa to file bankruptcy still
alive no he's not was he when you looked
that up
uh yes he was you ever talked to him
about it i didn't i didn't have the
heart to do it i didn't blame him i
don't know he's a true hero you know
what you don't want to shame him that's
okay i don't blame you just be
interesting and you know i think about
him right now he's he's up there smiling
and having looking at this oh i know
he's just pretty cool this is pretty
cool you've changed your family tree
dude well done very well done
good stuff got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the next chapter
in your story baby steps millionaires
that's what you'll be before you know it
probably by the time you're 30 at the
route you're going ding ding man
excellent excellent and a copy of total
money makeover for you to give to
somebody else and thanks for going
through financial peace university we
appreciate that i'm glad it was a
blessing to you
very very well done all right travis and
ashley fayetteville arkansas
195 000 paid off house and everything in
six years they're only 28 years old
making 76 up to 160 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
that's how it's done right there baby
change the family tree change the google
search now when you google travis's name
his debt-free story is going to show up
there's that this little youtube video
right here
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today first samuel 16 7
the lord does not look at the things
people look at
people look at the outward appearance
but the lord looks at the heart
theodore roosevelt said every time we
face our fear we gain strength courage
and confidence
in the doing
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you haven't heard we
launched pre-sale on the first book i
have done in eight years
today a brand new book that comes out
january the 11th you can start
purchasing it now
with all kinds of extras added on about
a hundred dollars worth of goodies if
you pre-purchase baby steps
millionaires
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth
and how you can too
ben is with us in tuscaloosa hi ben
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you how are you doing great what's
up
so i am currently a graduating senior at
the university of alabama i'm getting my
accounting degree and as of yet i am
debt free i got a full ride scholarship
good for you
so
well thank you so right now i am looking
into a master's program to get my 150
hours and meet my cpa requirement
and i'm considering university of
alabama or ut austin
and the reason i'm considering ut austin
is it is the number one program in the
country for accountants
uh
alabama's number 11.
and alabama's going to cost me about 30
000. ut austin would cost me about 50.
so i would be in debt for that amount
and i'm wondering if it would be worth
it
you'd be in debt for what amount
uh either the 30 000 or the 50 000. so
you don't have the money to go get your
masters
i don't have cash for it so i'd be good
so you got scholarships for your
undergrad at alabama why can't you get
scholarships for your masters
uh i could look into it um
might be worth 30 grand
yeah that's true can you work as an
accountant once you graduate before you
get the masters or a while
i am working this summer i got an
internship i had one last summer as well
they've given me a full-time offer
at about 60 a year
um are you going to take it oh i have
that
uh i am unsure i'm
looking around at other companies it's
with a smaller firm
and i'd like to go public accounting i
think there's a little bit better of a
career outlook well here's my question
to you can't you work for a year and
save up and then cash flow it the year
after to get that masters
why is the only option to go into that
because i'd like to get my cpa as soon
as possible
all right ben you called a show that
tells people to never borrow money
so we're gonna tell you never borrow
money
all right and then i'll answer your
original question before we let you off
the air okay so if i if you were my kid
and my kids are older than you um i will
put my arm around you and say you are
going to work my son
and uh you are going to work for someone
for a little while and you're going to
save up and pay cash for this masters
and just because you want your cpa
sooner well yeah you want to bentley
sooner too but you don't can't afford
one you know the money for it so you're
not getting a bentley either um and so
um or whatever car is your dream but the
uh
you can't afford it you don't have the
money uh the other option is go get
enough scholarships and go on
scholarship and just keep going um
that's fine either one of those is fine
uh
so
but yeah
and oh by the way you could go to work
for someone who has a program that will
pay for your masters so i suspect the
people paying you 60 might pay for your
masters
if you went to work there for if you
agree to stay there for a little while
they might pay for it you might ask them
about that as part of the signing
sign-on program if you want me to come
i'll be happy to take 50 if you pay for
my master's not 60
and i'll go to work full-time and i'll
work my master's in the evenings and
take the job and work your masters as an
adult curriculum not as a student
curriculum
and do it that way now the difference in
school number one and school number 11
isn't spit
there's two jobs in america that give a
rep
and with two companies
everybody else doesn't give a crap
as a matter of fact if you're working in
accounting and you want to come to work
at ramsey solutions and we have a large
finance and accounting department and
you make a lot more than 60 with your
master's degree and your cpa and you
want to move into corporate america so
to speak we're not corporate america in
the negative sense but we're a large
company and you wanted to come to work
here we wouldn't care whether you went
to the university of texas university of
alabama university of tennessee
university of georgia
we might even hire you if you went to
university of florida so i mean
but you know but the point being that an
account masters in accounting is a
masters in accounting and dude as you
have already discovered accounting is
really not a flexible uh world it's a
world that has a set of rules and you
will follow the rules if you're doing
accounting properly that's simple and
the difference in number one and the
number 11 is both of you follow the
rules there is no difference i wouldn't
s not a chance i would pay more money to
go the number one school not a chance
i'm ready i look at it like alabama's 45
off there you go there's a deal
comparatively to austin and i don't
think you're gonna you have hard data
that shows hey i'm gonna make 500 000
more if i go to ut austin as an
accountant
so there's that's why i go stay at
alabama but cash flow it work for a year
i know you want to be a cpa and it's
going to happen soon you can work for a
year and save up and pay for this yeah
i'm not sure we talked you into it but
you called here and asked so that's what
you get for your answer
bill's in dayton ohio hey bill welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
good well i'm a financial peace disciple
i'm a weirdo uh debt-free and
mortgage-free kind of guy and the
baby-step millionaire way to go way to
go
well i've got a uh question though um
trying to decide whether i should lease
my condo or not if i move overseas for a
job
uh
how long you'll be going overseas
uh it's probably three to five years i'd
sell it
so i figured you say that i know you
don't like long distance
you are a financial peace disciple
landlording you're right i don't yeah so
what's what country are you going to
what are you going to be doing
uh well so i was uh so i'm trying to get
out of rural ohio and i'm
was putting in for jobs other places you
know nicer places and
finally i said you know what i need to
pay off this condo so they paid it off
and literally the next day i got a job
offer in germany so germany what do you
do yes ma'am i work for the air force oh
god well thank you for your service
you mean you are you are serving in the
military in the air force is that what
you're saying no i'm actually retired
air force and i'm a civil servant for
the air force
the way you said that i wondered okay
all right yeah your phrasing tipped me
off and is it a three to five year
contract
uh well i think it's a three year
minimum you can extend um
you know for a year or two
okay sounds fun and i'm uh
yeah i'm well i'm 55 years old so you
know start thinking about that final
retirement place but this would be a fun
fun thing in the meantime maybe yeah a
little bit of an adventure huh yeah do
they pay for your housing there or
what's the housing situation in germany
well so that's the deal so now you know
part of the pay here is they give you a
uh locality pay
and since my house is paid off i'm
pocketing that but if i move overseas
that locality pay disappears and they
give you a housing allowance
which only matches your rent of the
place that you you know the house that
you rent so your rent is covered in
germany
right but i wouldn't be talking it would
be going straight to the landlords yeah
you're sure you used to pocket it now
yeah um yeah is there is there a raise
involved too
um no it's pretty much a lateral move
okay so
given the situation with the rent
payment you're actually taking a bit of
a pay cut to do this exactly exactly
yeah okay still sounds fun i'd go do it
yeah but i'd sell a condo
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't keep a condo
while i'm in germany
what would he do with the money once he
sells the house does he park that if
it's three to five years is it worth
i'm probably i'm probably putting in
mutual funds yeah so that um so sitting
there when i get back and i can do
something with it and it's you know this
market's doing really well and
three to five years and sounds like he's
probably going to be enjoying this a
while yeah sounds pretty good cool story
george campbell good show today fun
times well done james childs kelly
daniels in the booth i am dave ramsey
your host we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you